if you guys are new to the channel in
case you're not aware i put out this
book last fall the unplugged alpha is
the
title the playlist as well it is
something you should read if you have
not read it helps a lot of guys could
have helped this guy jake
i covered
in chapter one and in chapter 14
uh items that are relevant to
what happened and it's like it's
important guys like i want you to listen
up some some guys are like well you know
i don't want to hear it should be
covered let's just kind of move on from
it okay i get it
but you need to understand the severity
of
um
feeding your mind with man it's
like
i go and put diesel fuel and a mclaren
720 the engine's gonna blow up okay you
feed
you know yourself your mind your body
your cars your boats your toys with crap
they are not going to work properly
and i'm going to show you what happened
here with this guy
i mean i do a lot of digging on this and
it's unfortunate but
i think this lesson is important and
needs to be talked about so i just want
you to hear this kid's position and
you'll understand
the build-up on this and why this
happens so pay attention here
no i can't
i'm so beaten down and defeated by life
that drive that i once had that's gone
like
you know i try
and always keep trying
but it's it's like i'm at the point now
where it's like why do i even bother
like
for what
you know i'm still in the same house
same situation same position
still everything's still the same
for the most part it's just been
me against the world it's just been me
fighting an uphill battle with a big
rock on my back you know what i'm seeing
that don't deserve half of anything
all right so i'm just gonna pause it
there for a sec because he just made an
interesting point that i think we gotta
talk about for a second
he said
mf
that don't deserve half of what i
deserve
now i've written an extensive list of
everything that you guys deserve i have
i've worked very hard at this list
it's very long
and comprehensive and i'd like you to
look at it right now are you ready
this is what you're entitled to
nothing
you're a man you're entitled to nothing
in this world you need to work for it
i'm going to keep saying it
you're not entitled to a damn thing if
you're a man
if you're a woman if you're a child if
you're a dog
you're protected don't worry everybody
loves you doesn't matter what you do
but if you're a man you need to earn it
you're not
nobody's gonna hand anything to you
his belief system the mindset he's
approaching life from
it's broken from the get-go it's gonna
back it up a little bit and continue to
hit play so you can hear the rest of
that uphill battle
with a big
rock on my back you know
that don't deserve half
of anything no
they're getting a free road to the top
the whole premise of the interviews is
that you know everything's rigged
against you there's no hope for humanity
you know we're on the brink of
extinction you know and then this is
where he goes awol starting to talk
about thinking he's a terminator
and blah blah blah all right so
from the get-go
the problem with a lot of guys today is
they've been bubble wrapped
and
they start from a disadvantage they
start from a belief
that because they got a participation
trophy for showing up at track and field
all throughout elementary school in high
school and playing in uh extracurricular
sports baseball soccer everybody gets a
trophy in a ribbon now right there's no
first place second place and you know
it's just you all get ribbons we don't
want to hurt anybody's feelings that's
the world we live in today participation
trophies
contribute to problems like this and
i've said this many times and i'll
continue to repeat it i'm telling you
guys if you have children that are
playing sports and and there's no clear
winner or loser at the end of the
competitive cycle they're in the wrong
sport find another league find another
something where there's a clear winner
and a loser losers don't lose they need
to learn winners can celebrate okay
set that aside
so this so this is a kid from the
participation trophy generation
we have um let me see here a few
articles that i pulled up let's go to
his his father
because i mean the first thing that i
ask is where was his kid's father he was
not in the house he was not part of his
life at the time
and he was raised by a single mother for
the most part so
we've got an article here
it looks like
they
spent some time in the shetland islands
uh
father was a violent thug jailed for
attack
okay uh dude was a fisherman he's got
two older siblings this kid
jake joe and josh
uh they moved to plymouth
and
uh there's a few other things here about
some of his peppered history uh working
on fishing boats getting thrown off a
bus he was in jail for a while
uh
sources say that his father was
estranged for being a violent person
with a lengthy criminal record
and uh mom it's good blah okay we can
skip through that
and here we go
2014 this guy got a big scrap on a
scallop fishing boat this is his father
by the way so i mean like realistically
it seems like for the last 10 or 12
years
is old man didn't really play much of a
role
in the kids upbringing
and fathers are really important like
buy a wide margin and i've covered this
in my book and i've covered this in
other conversation topics buy a wide
margin kids that are raised in single
parents single mother households do far
worse than children from a two-parent
household whenever a guy says to me hey
rich you know i want to get a a
surrogate and have a child with a
cigarette i'm going to pay her and i'm
going to contract her then i'm going to
and annie to raise that i i always tell
them the same thing it's a bad idea man
kids need a mother and a father around
they get the strong masculine virtues
from the dad they get the softer tender
stuff you know from the mommy the dad's
a lot more important as a kid get gets
older because as they transition from
child to adulthood super important to
have both parents around cell but i
think the dad is critically important at
that point because they can teach them
critical skills like how to deal with
rejection when girls don't respond to
you favorably you know stuff like that
anyway so scalloper blah blah blah
there's another link down over here in
this article
here it is
uh girl 16 said now
this is him over here he's he's not in
terrible shape he's not in great shape
he's kind of a husky guy um he needs a
haircut
he needed
a little bit of
like a few style recommendations if you
will
um but apparently he was trying to
impose himself about a week before this
incident on a girl because he felt he
was entitled to where is it here in a
comment on
reddit by the way is cancer guys stay
away from that crap
uh am i not entitled to my
and i'm not going to read the rest of it
because it's youtube but he starts right
away from the position i'm entitled why
am i i am entitled to get this out of
life
you get the uh the point that i'm making
here yeah
uh this here is another article i came
across with family ties to it
this is a sister attractive girl
um
this is the
guy here
the sister
this is his other brother an older
brother handsome dude not a unattractive
family right like this guy had potential
he really did have potential if he
cleaned himself up lost the weight got a
proper haircut you know some style in
his beard
you know some style in the clothing and
i believe
what was his employment he was working
at j.o.b
he was basically working a just over
broke position
um
was it mentioned in this article
i can't find it now but he but he was
found in
i think this is the father and daughter
that was taken out as well but he was
found in some of the photography wearing
those uh stripy um you know work vests
don't know what he did
apparently there was not a lot of
commentary on that it looks like the
employer wanted to stay out of the
picture
all right so we got uh the entitlement
part there's some family stuff over here
the family's of course devastated
family's a good looking family you know
he had the potential to do something
more
uh this is the most recent article that
i came across so i wanted to get the
most up-to-date stuff here
now
interestingly enough they're not framing
this as a toxic masculinity they're
framing this more from the perspective
of
now in cell slash black pill
okay we're gonna get to that second part
in just one second
incel is a word that gets thrown around
a lot i mean
you you say anything that it that shines
a light on the true nature between men
and women and what drives arousal and
attraction
usually what you'll get is
um women coming at you calling you an
insult or something like that right
okay fine doesn't bother me
guys like this it seemed to bother
though right
um
zero respect uh bitter and jealous
uh what are some of the other sound
bites he was he was he wasn't pleased
with the women obviously you know he
there's some sound bites here around
them being uh entitled and arrogant
beyond belief
um and of course you know when he made
his it advances
towards that younger girl she was 16
he's 23. that's way too much of a a
spread at that age in my view but
anyway you know he's he's trying to
impose himself and like he's entitled to
something and then he gets pissed off
because he calls them uh what do you
call them arrogant
beyond belief yeah
um
where's the points here in this plymouth
left six and queries continue
in cell subreddit
stay away from
reddit guys it's it's it's cancer it's
honestly it's a
place why would you go to a place on the
internet where people dispense advice
when you cannot evaluate the source of
the advice i've said this many times
always consider the source you get some
random you know alpha wolf 420 telling
you
you know how to live your life you don't
know what they're doing for a living you
don't know what kind of money they got
you don't even know if they interact you
don't even know if they're fit or if
they're fat why would you take the
advice of some random on a reddit stay
off reddit man it is just stay away from
it any of these like
and this kid you know
he goes there dives down this rabbit
hole of nihilism
and hopelessness and you're not going to
be able to succeed in life because of
insert all of the reasons why you're a
loser
like i've said the loser content on the
internet is out there it's out on
youtube it's out on web pages
uh this kid goes to an exit forum for
incels designed to help men looking for
a way out
uh
he suggested his toxic views had
permanently corrupted him
he says i personally don't think once
you live this life you can really ever
change the damage down i personally
believe my scars and damage will follow
me forever he stated
it also appears to blame the incel black
pill philosophy for his state of
increasing hopelessness in the period
before the embarking's killing spree
blah blah blah black pulls a fatalist
outlook
this is him again with the bad haircut
and beard
and cell movements promoted now
the media twists us way out of
proportion they start going on about how
it's all got to do with stuff that's not
even related to the problem the real
question that should that should have
been asked here is
where was the old man what kind of role
did he play in this kid's life you know
what was going on in the guy's household
and why did he have these entitlement
issues and why did he not know how to
deal with rejection and finally why did
he not know what women are actually
attracted to what women actually respond
to
right he didn't
he just didn't
uh
text
i think that was it for this article
here now there was an interesting uh
cast that uh john
from modern life dating did on saturday
after the rule zero you can go to his
channel it's number 58
and he pinned a comment at the top which
i want to read to you guys
i'll go larger screen here so you can
see it
just zoom in here a little bit more
yeah you should be able to see that now
okay so so this guy um who john pinned
towards the top he said formal black
former black pillar here
i wasn't deep into the culture i just
but i stumbled upon it and started
consuming content like better bachelor
in brackets joker and sandman it was
cathartic because it was a way to vent
my frustration and know that others felt
the same way in other words i wasn't
crazy or the only one but it got old
really quick i'm naturally an optimistic
person and the constant negativity and
nihilism were eating away at my soul
no solutions were offered
okay
what do we do
when we're talking together on rule zero
what do i do when i'm talking on my
channel in videos what did i do in my
book when i put all the information
together for you guys i presented you
with solutions to the problem anybody
that's selling you a problem
wants to sell you misery
it's loser talk it is not going to help
you it is not going to help you level up
in life it is content that you must
avoid as a man you must avoid it you
must make ensure that anybody around you
that consumes it does their best to
avoid it
i'm going to keep reading what he's
saying over here
there you go full screen
uh blue pill program feeling frustrated
angry and resentful towards women sound
familiar with what this jake guy had
experienced with the experiences that he
had posted online a borderline actual
misogynist he put in brackets there
while still trying to be nice in the
hope that i might find the one even
though the cracks in that particular
belief were becoming too obvious to
ignore then i started consuming oh sorry
i missed this point over here with no
solutions offered i remember finishing
one of joker's videos and thinking
that's it i'm screwed i don't have a
chance what's the point
now
i'm not gonna blame joker the better
bachelor channel for
stuff like this but i will say this
he doesn't offer solutions he's reading
articles and basically saying see there
you go
that's it
and then you do what you want i think
that if you're a guy talking to other
men about problems in men's lives you
need to be offering solutions to them
and
this guy over here uh daniel
earl that was the same conclusion that i
came to at some point i think it was uh
aaron cleary that sent me a video one
time he goes you know i was binge
watching this joker guy and you got to
check it out
you know i watched a few videos and i
thought oh okay that's that's
interesting it's kind of like mgtow
light like you know
whatever um but i basically got to the
same conclusion like what's the point
like where are the solutions
anyway at the time he got deeply
entrenched feeling frustrated angry uh
cracks ignore then i started consuming
stuff from entrepreneurs and cars and
the rational male
there was a stark difference
shocking right i actually started
learning about female nature rather than
being confused by it and actual
solutions were proposed
thanks to guys like john rollo rich and
ryan i'm actually improving my life
starting to earn more look better
learning game and i actually got laid
and a retrospective i have of my black
pill phase that i felt entitled
what did this kid say he was entitled to
a girl he was entitled to half the stuff
that the other guys were complaining
that sorry we're getting that he felt
entitled to get
you hear that word entitled a lot in
that space right they feel entitled and
didn't want a shoulder to shoulder the
burden of performance that all men must
face i wanted it to be easy any doomers
who don't like it can get bent
there you have it guys
go get bent
you